I don't understand how people don't
follow human attention human attention
is the asset people ask me all the time
what if something gets banned what if
something changes I'm always like then
the attention is going to go somewhere
I'll run print ads if the whole world's
reading magazines
over the next five years you'll have
people that move faster
on using AI for Content creation and
they'll get a land grab but somewhere in
the next decade or two it'll be no
different than using a search engine so
there'll be a window right now where
there'll be Leaders with who will create
and they'll create more content more
specific the AI will do a better job
than even people that have spent 20
years trying to be good at it and that's
fine and that will be normalized the
problem is or the opportunity is what
will be the next step more importantly
the critical thinking of the input
becomes a really interesting game
you know it's really funny for me to
watch all these schools and universities
ban all these products they'd rather
have kids memorize information that's a
commodity then start teaching people
critical thinking of inputting into the
AI products which is actually the punch
line I was like wait a minute this is
what I've been waiting for my whole life
I've never been good at the commodity I
can't put seven sentences together that
are proper grammar but I can come up
with the ideas that actually matter and
so I'm actually very excited I've heard
a lot of people talk about this is bad
for the creative industry I'm like this
is the greatest thing that's ever
happened in the creative industry it's
just going to be the greatest thing that
happens to the creative people the
commodity of creativity executing it
that's going to be commoditized but
that's what's always happened that's
what the tractor did to farming
innovation's always going to do this so
I think the interesting thing is twofold
one this is about to expose the most
creative critical thinkers and I think
she and he is going to have a very good
you know decade two three four and two
it's still going to come down to the
idea you know you're still gonna have to
input like write me a sentence in the
voice of Porky Pig that talks about like
you're still gonna have to come up with
that I think that ideas and creativity
have always mattered I think the process
of getting to ideas both in Madison
Avenue and advertising and in the
creative field has actually become
clunky inefficient and rewards a lot of
people that don't bring any value to it
I think AI is going to have a very big
impact on separating the people that
have great ideas versus the ones that
don't and I think it's gonna be
interesting to watch I don't understand
how people don't follow human attention
human attention is the asset people ask
me all the time what if something gets
banned what if something changes Vine
used to be big then it got bought I'm
always like then the attention is going
to go somewhere if all of social media
disappears off the face of the Earth
tomorrow that's an opportunity for me
because 8 billion people are still going
to put their attention somewhere whether
that's connected TV whether that's AV AR
VR like it's the attention is going to
go I'll run print ads if the whole
world's reading magazines
so I think this emotion
the emotion of holding up a distribution
platform
is a humongous vulnerability I'm just
prepared on an everyday basis to wake up
and adjust to where humans have given
their attention I also think it's a good
idea to bring value to people you know I
think what's really evolved in the death
of Television ads is that not only have
we over the last two decades moved our
attention to other polypses with the
growth and expansion of the internet but
the value proposition of a commercial on
television is zero if the ads happen to
be decent somewhat interesting somewhat
intriguing
it could still be a much more viable
medium than it is today it's why the
Super Bowl in America continues to work
but you know they're just not and by the
way most tick tocks are not valuable
either it's just there's so many of them
on a daily basis that even if one
percent is good that's a lot of good
whereas television commercials are low
there's not so many of them and none of
them are good I would argue a lot of the
ads are not good but it's a cultural
phenomenon to tune in this morning I'm
reading the team talking globally on
WhatsApp and they're like the Oscars
were up 18 in viewership and my
contribution was but nobody watched the
ads the Oscars might be up 18 because
we're getting out of into a post-covered
world and I also think there's a huge
opportunity for someone to innovate the
world is so fragmented now think about
how your product works your product is
based on the interest graph not the
social graph but what happens when you
build on the interest graph is we get
into a fragmented world so I actually
think the Oscars were up 18 in America
because humans are subconsciously
yearning for joint experience the World
Cup is fun because we're all watching
the same thing we're getting pushed not
just by your platform the world is going
in one direction we will be fragmented
which means there's an opportunity for
10 or 20 things to bring us all together
there's incredible opportunity for that
but I think it's not that there's good
ads really I think more than half of
them are a complete waste of 20 million
dollars I think it's just a cultural
phenomenon for us to all be joined in
and so I'm excited about that I'm
excited about the evolution of us
finding new things for all of us to
watch together maybe even globally now
that we're all connected
all right